- So the Trump indictments are here,
but they're not the ones
that most people expected.
On July 1st, Donald Trump's
chief financial officer,
Allen Weisselberg,
surrendered after Manhattan
District Attorney,
Cy Vance, charged Weisselberg
and the Trump organization
with 15 criminal offenses
including conspiracy,
grand larceny, criminal tax
fraud, and falsifying records.
The indictment alleges a, quote,
"sweeping and audacious payment scheme,"
that allowed Weisselberg and others
be paid more compensation
than the company taxpayers
reported to tax authorities.
The charges center on unpaid
taxes on employee benefits
that Weisselberg and his
family allegedly received.
The benefits include things
like free apartments,
cash bonuses, comped Mercedes cars,
and private school tuition for his kids.
And after the announcement,
many of Trump's critics rejoiced
with many reminiscing about
the time that Al Capone went
to prison for tax evasion
rather than for murder,
and the #LockHimUp trended
on Twitter all morning.
So is this really it?
Is the hammer really truly
about to fall on Donald Trump,
his company, his
associates, and his family?
Well, it depends.
(triumphant instrumental music)
Hey, Legal Eagles.
It's time to think
like a white collar
criminal defense attorney
because former president Trump
waged a year's long battle
with Cy Vance over subpoenas
into his tax records.
When the Supreme Court
ruled that Trump had
to turn over his tax information to Vance,
he and New York Attorney
General Letitia James announced
that they were collaborating
on several investigations.
But the Vance indictments
don't have anything
to do with Trump's personal taxes
or at least the way that
he values his properties.
So the question is,
is the Weisselberg
indictment the opening salvo
in a bigger war over Donald
Trump's tax avoidance strategies
and are the feds coming next?
And also, can Weisselberg
himself beat this rap?
Well, today, I'm going to
shed light on what we know
about the Trump organization case.
Of course, keep in mind as always,
this is just an indictment,
and nothing has been proven
against either Weisselberg
or the Trump organization.
Both he and the company
have pleaded not guilty
to these criminal charges.
So to get into this, let's
establish some basic things
about the area of tax law.
Employees and corporations pay taxes
on an employee's compensation.
In addition to salary,
compensation includes things
like tuition, housing, and cars
if the employer provides
them, and under the tax code,
these are classified as fringe benefits.
According to the IRS,
any fringe benefit that
you receive as an employee
is taxable and must be
included in the recipient's pay
unless the law specifically excludes it.
Employers can deduct employee compensation
from the taxes that they owe,
but they still have to pay Medicare
and social security
taxes to the government.
These are payroll taxes.
Generally, the employer pays
half of the payroll taxes,
and the employee pays the rest.
Now, if a corporation can
find a way to classify some
of the employee compensation
as a deductible expense,
it avoids the payroll taxes
saving approximately 14%
that would've gone to the government.
This also pays off for the employees
since disguising compensation
as a routine business expense
avoids not only the payroll
taxes but also the income taxes
that would be owed by the employee.
Now here, prosecutors allege
the Trump organization
has been engaged to defraud federal state
and local tax authorities
starting as far back as 2005.
The scheme was two pronged.
First, it involved allowing employees
to dramatically understate
their compensation
so they could pay less tax.
This also allowed the
company to obtain tax refunds
on taxes already deducted
and paid to tax authorities.
Second, the company has failed
to withhold income taxes
on wages, salaries, bonuses,
and other forms of compensation,
allowing allegedly the Trump organization
to evade the payment of payroll taxes
that the organization was required to pay
in connection with employee compensation.
As the indictment explains,
no one benefited more
from this alleged tax evasion
scheme than Allen Weisselberg,
who was in charge of
the company's finances.
Weisselberg is firmly enmeshed
in the Trump organization's business.
Former Trump fixer Michael
Cohen told Congress
that Weisselberg helped him pay
off adult film star Stormy
Daniels and other women
who had affairs with Trump.
Cohen also testified
that he and Weisselberg,
quote, "concocted phony valuations,
the company's real estate holdings
that suit Mr. Trump's
needs at any given moment."
Weisselberg was also a key
person in the investigation
over the misuse of the charitable funds
by the Donald J. Trump Foundation,
which resulted in Trump himself admitting
that he used charity funds to buy things
for his golf clubs and
presidential campaigns.
And the Trumps paid $2 million
to settle the case and are now barred
from chartering another
nonprofit in New York.
Many expected Trump to pardon Weisselberg,
but he did not do so.
Now the Manhattan DA alleges
that Weisselberg was able
to, quote, "receive indirect
employee compensation
from the Trump organization
in the approximate amount
of $1.76 million."
The indictment alleges
that the Trump companies
helped Weisselberg get paid in ways
that helped the companies
avoid reporting it
to tax authorities.
So let's talk about the first count
against Weisselberg and
the corporate defendants,
which was a scheme to defraud in violation
of New York penal code section 190.65.
A person is guilty of a scheme to defraud
in the first degree, if he or she, quote,
"engages in a scheme constituting
a systemic ongoing course
of conduct with intent to defraud more
than one person or
obtain property for more
than one person by false
or fraudulent pretenses,
representations, or promises,
and so obtains property
with a value in excess of $1,000
from one or more such persons."
Now this isn't usually an offense
that's charged as a single count.
It's usually charged in connection
with other offenses, as it is here.
And in essence, a felony scheme to defraud
is basically an accusation that someone
was running some kind of scam
with the intent to steal.
And when Weisselberg and his wife moved
into a Trump building on
Riverside Boulevard in 2005,
the Trump organization paid their rent,
the garage, and four utilities.
According to the DA,
the expenses constituted
employee compensation
and taxable income to Weisselberg.
And in an almost cartoonish
example of tax evasion,
these payments involved some
extremely tricky bookkeeping.
The DA claims that "these
payments were not booked
to the Trump organization's general ledger
as employee compensation
but were instead labeled
and deducted as," quote,
"'rent expense' in the general ledger.
However, for certain years,
the Trump organization
maintained internal that
tracked the amounts it paid
for Weisselberg's rent,
utility, and garage expenses."
So did you catch that?
The Trump organization allegedly
kept two sets of books,
one with the fake numbers and one
with the real figures paid to Weisselberg.
The indictment says that
when the Trump corporation
paid Weisselberg's rent,
someone from the Trump organization
reduced Weisselberg's salary
by a corresponding amount.
If this is true, this is
extremely strong evidence
of intent that makes it
much harder for Weisselberg
and the corporation to argue that it
was all an accident or misunderstanding.
- We know what we're gonna do?
- Till the gunman indicts, anyway.
- Now people who are
skeptical about the charges
have suggested the tax authorities
are attacking the Trump
organization for political reasons,
and one way to prove that
would be to show that people
are rarely prosecuted for
this kind of tax fraud.
However, people do go to
jail for the same conduct
that Weisselberg is accused of.
In fact, one of Trump's
old pals, Leona Helmsley,
was sentenced to four years in prison
for having her real estate company pay
to renovate her Greenwich
mansion and then failing
to report those payments as income.
The man who prosecuted Helmsley was,
and I'm not kidding you,
Rudy Giuliani. (laughs)
By the time that Helmsley was charged,
she and Trump had a falling out,
and Trump celebrated the charges
with a letter calling her, quote,
"a disgrace to the industry
and a disgrace to humanity in general."
And there's more.
The DA said that from 2005 to 2013,
Weisselberg pretended not to
be a resident of New York City
in order to avoid paying city taxes.
Weisselberg listed his
home in upstate New York
as his permanent residence
all while spending most
of his time living and working in the city
that the Trump organization
allegedly paid for.
And this is a common scheme
to evade paying local taxes,
and, in fact, in another
similar situation,
Derek Chauvin, yes, the former
Minneapolis police officer
convicted of murdering George Floyd,
was actually charged with
aiding and abetting tax fraud
in Washington County, Minnesota.
Chauvin and his wife claimed
to be legal residents
of Florida while Chauvin worked full-time
as an officer in Minnesota.
The couple then filed tax returns claiming
to be Florida residents.
Now the district attorney also
claims that Trump employees,
including Weisselberg,
arranged for tuition expenses
for Weisselberg's family members.
This money was allegedly
paid by personal checks drawn
on the account of and
signed by Donald J. Trump.
The DA says that these payments, quote,
"constituted employee compensation
and taxable income to Allen Weisselberg
and was treated as part of
Weisselberg annual compensation
and internal records maintained
by the Trump corporation."
So once again, the real
compensation was included
in a secret ledger of
payments to Weisselberg
but not included on Weisselberg's W2 forms
or reported to tax authorities.
And the companies did
withhold income taxes
on the tuition payments, and
Weisselberg allegedly failed
to report about $359,000
in tuition expenses
for family members.
And Donald, Jr. has seemingly
admitted that his father
was aware of in part of this arrangement.
- It's not 1.7 million. That's income.
The taxable portion of that
to New York state is 8%.
That's $136,000 over 16 years.
That's 10 grand a year.
Half of that, because
my father's a good guy,
he paid for this guy's
grandchildren's education.
Our tax experts say
that's not even taxable.
- All right, so a couple
of things stand out here.
It seems the legal strategy
of the Trump family
is to say that whatever
Weisselberg was doing,
Trump was not aware of it,
but he may have been aware
of it because he's such a nice guy,
but also this is all
Weisselberg's responsibility
because he's the CFO.
So we can listen to former
president Trump in his own words.
- Or education for your
grandchildren. I don't even know.
Does anybody know the
answer to that stuff?
- And so far, others have
reported and Don, Jr.
has confirmed that these
checks were written
by Donald Trump, Sr. personally
for Weisselberg's compensation.
And even if Trump was
personally signing the checks,
which reports indicate
that he was doing even
as late as 2017, he'll
claim that he signs hundreds
if not thousands of checks a month,
and that's just part of doing business.
So he, again, would be relying on his CFO,
Allen Weisselberg, who
obviously was the bad actor
in this particular case.
Whether a jury would believe that
or not is an open question.
These things are hard.
It's hard to prove these tax prosecutions.
And the statements from Don,
Jr. seem to be a preview
of a defense that we're going to see
down the line because any amount
of tuition reimbursement
that exceeds $5,250
is considered a fringe benefit of the job.
So it seems like he's arguing
that although the tuition
is around $10,000 a year,
Trump, Sr. only paid
for half of that, making it non-taxable.
And of course, one can pay for tuition.
That's fine, but the
tuition can't be claimed
as a deductible business
expense if it's not.
Additionally, the indictment alleges
that the Trump companies
paid annual lease expenses
on two Mercedes-Benzes
that were the personal cars
of Weisselberg and his wife.
The end result was that
neither the corporation
or Weisselberg paid taxes on $196,000
in compensation for the cars.
The Trump organization
also gave Weisselberg
over $29,000 in cash to
distribute as holiday bonuses.
The company allegedly
wrote checks to an employee
and had that employee give
the cash to Weisselberg.
The Trump corporation
allegedly booked this cash
as holiday entertainment
but maintained internal
spreadsheets showing the cash
to be part of Weisselberg's
employee compensation.
Of course, no taxes were reported or paid.
So according to this, the Trump executives
weren't even hiding what they were doing.
They kept track of it all on a spreadsheet
in complete confidence so
the IRS would never know.
It was allegedly right
there in black and white.
And then there's a whole
slew of allegations
regarding ad hoc personal expenses.
Weisselberg's compensation
allegedly included payment
of expenses on homes and apartments used
by Weisselberg's family.
This was for things like carpet,
new beds, giant TVs, and furniture.
The Trump companies meticulously, quote,
"tracked the payment of
the expenses internally
as part of Weisselberg's
annual compensation."
And the same set up was
used to pay the expenses
and rent of other employees,
including two of
Weisselberg's family members.
Although these people aren't named,
the "New York Times" reported
that Weisselberg's children
also benefited from the
association with Trump.
Weisselberg's son Barry got a job
with the Trump organization
managing the Wollman Rink
in Central Park and played DJ
for the Trump Christmas parties.
Yes, real shades of
"Succession's" cousin Greg.
Egg, Greg. I don't know.
And then we have bonuses,
and speaking of the Wollman skating rink,
the indictment alleges
that the Trump companies
used subsidiaries to
pay some executives end
of the year bonuses that
were then misreported
as non-employee compensation,
violation of federal law.
The companies playing along with a scheme
included the Wollman Rink,
Trump International Golf Club,
Mar-a-Lago Trump Las
Vegas Development, LLC,
and other entities.
This corporate sleight of hand
allegedly allowed Weisselberg
and others to receive
non-employee compensation
that allowed them to participate
in a tax-deferred pension
plan that otherwise
wouldn't have been available
as an employee of the Trump organization.
And the district attorney says
that Weisselberg knowingly
falsified records
in furtherance of the scheme.
He repeatedly reported
that his compensation
was fixed at 940,000, quote,
"comprised of $540,000
in base salary and 400,000
in end of the year bonuses."
But Vance says that the Trump corporation
at Weisselberg's direction "excluded
from his reported gross income the amounts
that were paid to him indirectly."
So the rent, cars, cash, furniture,
and tuition were purposefully
hidden from tax authorities.
And then there are a whole raft
of other interesting related charges.
Weisselberg was charged with conspiracy
to commit second-degree larceny.
Generally, for this kind of claim,
a prosecutor has to show three things
to prove this conspiracy,
which in and of itself
is not a separate charge.
First, you have to show
that the involvement
of two or more people;
second, the criminal intent,
which means people must know that they
are doing something illegal; and third,
at least one of the conspirators has
to take overt action in
furtherance of the conspiracy.
And one of the interesting
things about this charge
is that it brings us back to the return
of unindicted co-conspirator number one.
It's been a while since we've heard
about this particular character.
And in earlier seasons of
"As the Trump World Turns,"
Robert Mueller presented a long report
describing potentially
criminal acts committed
by individual number one,
and Michael Cohen went
to jail for conspiracy
with unindicted co-conspirator number one.
Both of these people are
presumed pretty obviously
to be Donald Trump, but
in this particular case,
individual one may not
actually be Donald Trump.
In fact, many have reported
that the most likely candidate
for this particular unindicted
co-conspirator number one
is Trump organization
comptroller Jeff McConney.
But what was this conspiracy about?
Well, the district attorney
says that from, quote,
"at least 2005 through the
date of this indictment,
the named defendants and others,
including unindicted
co-conspirator number one,
agreed to an implemented
the compensation scheme
with the object of enabling Weisselberg
to underreport his income
to federal authorities
and thereby evade taxes
and falsely claim federal tax refund,
to which he was not entitled.
As a result of the conspirators' actions,
during the period of the conspiracy,
Weisselberg took approximately $94,900."
And to satisfy the requirements
of the conspiracy law,
the indictment lays forth the
overt acts that Weisselberg
and others allegedly took in
furtherance of this conspiracy.
I'm not gonna read them
to you, but you can see
that the acts include
underreporting income,
and, effectively, many people
were involved in scheme.
Then there are claims of grand larceny.
Prosecutors have a lot of
options in these kinds of cases
for charging people with the theft
of state money that
should have been taxed,
including the charge of grand larceny.
So count three involves
the predicate offense
for the conspiracy grand larceny,
and Weisselberg is charged
with second-degree larceny
in violation of penal code section 155.40.
A person is guilty of grand
larceny in the second degree
when he steals property
valued at more than $50,000.
And then there are the
criminal tax fraud claims.
Counts four, five, six,
and seven charged the Trump
corporations and Weisselberg
with third and fourth
degree criminal tax fraud.
A person commits criminal
tax fraud in the third degree
if they performed a,
quote, "tax fraud act."
The tax code of New
York defines a tax fraud
as "intentionally providing
materially false information
on a tax return or during a tax audit
or failing to intentionally pay taxes owed
to the state of New York.
The defendant's actions
must be intentional
with the intent to defraud,
and the defendant must
have defrauded the state
for at least a one-year
period in the amount greater
than $10,000 but not more than $50,000."
And then there are the counts
related to falsifying records.
Counts eight through
15 are for various acts
of falsifying business records.
Weisselberg is charged with four counts
of offering a false instrument for filing,
a violation of New York penal code 175.35.
He's specifically charged
with a first-degree felony.
The prosecution here has to prove first
that he knowingly offered
a written document
or instrument that contains
a false statement on its face
and presented it, quote,
"to a public authority,
public servant, or public office."
Second, the prosecution has to
show the document was filed,
registered, or became a party
of that particular office's records,
and third, this is a felony crime
if the person acts with
the intent to defraud.
And while the intent to defraud
is a complicated concept,
in New York, it's been
interpreted as an act
or behavior where the
goal is to lead another
into error or disadvantage.
This doesn't necessarily
mean that the person needed
to present a false document
for the purpose of stealing money.
It's enough to show that the
defendant wanted to interfere
with the government's ability
to administer the law.
And the Trump corporations
and Weisselberg are charged
with falsifying business
records in the first degree
in violation of penal code section 175.10,
which states, quote, "A person is guilty
of falsifying business
records in the first degree
when he commits the crime of
falsifying business records
in the secondary end when his intent
to defraud includes his
intent to commit another crime
or to aid or conceal in
the commission thereof."
The defendants were accused
of fraud in connection
with three years of
filing Weisselberg's W2's,
and the 15th count is
particularly interesting
because it alleges that
the Trump organization
and Weisselberg acted to
basically cover up their tracks.
Manhattan district attorney
general counsel Carey Dunne
provided additional information
during the arraignment.
Quote, "The CFO himself
directed the company records
be deleted to conceal his
participation in the scheme.
Even now, there's been no
attempt to impose discipline
on the people involved,
to report the crimes,
to repay the proceeds,
or even to amend any
of the false tax returns.
Instead, when confronted
by our investigation,
the company at its
highest levels decided not
to accept responsibility and to cooperate,
which is what companies do if they want
to be viewed as a good corporate citizen.
Instead, it forced us into
litigation for a year and a half,
including two trips to the Supreme Court."
Falsifying business
records in the first degree
is a class E felony, which
can result in prison time
but often results in just
probation, fines, and the like.
On the other hand, maybe everyone
at the Trump organization
is just really bad at
taxes and accounting.
But the best place for Allen Weisselberg
to brush up on his business
acumen is not Trump University.
It's at today's sponsor, Skillshare,
which offers classes on
how to manage every aspect
of new business ventures.
Allen Weisselberg and Donald
Trump could really benefit
from Emily Simcox's Skillshare class,
Bookkeeping for Freelancers.
The class teaches students everything
on how to choose the
right bookkeeping method,
how to organize and track expenses,
and how to stay organized
throughout the year,
even years you're being
impeached or audited.
Simcox breaks down the ins
and outs of bookkeeping
in terms that even a
graduate of Trump University
could understand because
Skillshare has classes
on almost everything, from video to music
to business and entrepreneurship.
Skillshare, as you know,
is one of the world's
largest online communities
with tens of thousands
of classes on everything
and is the best place to get
a start on the internet or,
if you're an accountant for
one of the Trump organizations,
learning accounting for the first time.
Now, if you'd like to try out Skillshare,
the first 1,000 Legal
Eagles to use my link
in the description will get a free trial
of Skillshare Premium.
And for a limited time, the
trial is for an entire month,
not just 14 days as usual.
Plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So just click on the link to
get a free trial of Skillshare,
and click on this other link for all
of my other real law reviews,
or I'll see you in court.